I'm married okay I didn't tell you I
know you didn't I was afraid you
wouldn't want to see me again we were
right but I already know she did already
know because she saw the wife that's a
scene from last Sunday's dramatic
episode of the affair is Alison
confronts her boyfriend Ben Alison is
portrayed by actress Ruth Wilson Ruth
Wilson is very busy she's also in the
upcoming supernatural thriller on the
big screen it's called Little Stranger
the little stranger she plays a troubled
British aristocrat his family's life has
changed after a doctor is called to care
for them those marks whilst disturbing
even I felt that they're nothing more
than they appear
it's the heating patch I imagine yeah we
haven't had the heating on Sinai's
contracting in the cold Caroline you
mustn't let this business get inside you
will be explained
thirty I so glad you're here we're so
glad with Wilson yeah welcome back at
the table Ruth we want to talk about the
affair in just a second guys I'm very
not happy with how it's ending it so
we'll get to that in just a second talk
about the little string yes this thing I
don't know if it's a it's a supernatural
thriller if it's a psychological
thriller if it's a couple of times
during the key scenes I wasn't sure it's
real or is it an imagined is that what
you wanted the viewer to do to go on
quite a ride with you yeah I mean look
it's an adaptation a Sarah novels book
yeah and it does cover lots of different
genres it kind of doesn't stick to it's
not defined by one so it's got a
structure of a ghost story
yeah but in that is a psychological
drama really and it's a period drama and
it's a family drama and it's a romance
and there's all sorts of things going on
but we which did romance sued yes though
it's about this doctor comes into this
crumbling family mansion and things
start to go wrong and throughout it's a
question whether it's supernatural
or is it psychological but yeah you are
leaving with questions rather than
solution and Gale and I have had a
debate over who the little stranger is
yeah well that's up to interpretation I
mean I always kind of thought it was it
was Donnell's that Faraday is kind of
inner dance and he's almost got it's
about repressed British people which you
know we keep all that emotion down and
it comes if you do that it's gonna come
out in some violent perhaps and it's
gonna come out some way down the line
and so that's kind of what it's about
it's sort of is this a poltergeist it
goes yes is it is it a demon of your own
making
yes so that's the sort of shabby-chic
aristocracy yeah that's a really
interesting period nostalgia we have I'm
not even British but I haven't started
for it anyway we have all do well I
think also it's interesting on why I was
drawn to this project was the
aristocracy in it aren't like the ones
in Downton Abbey they're not glamorous
they're not romanticized it's not like
the crown and you see the royalty these
are people in decline and they are like
Grey Gardens it's kind of like grade up
gardens meets the
you know it's sort of he's a very
eccentric odd characters that you find
through the wilderness you know I sort
of come to help these creatures and
that's why I love playing it was a real
character to kind of find and I had to
fake teeth in I had bum padding I had
like hip padding and let's do it okay
fair because it yeah you were no longer
with the show my no my disappointment
but that was such a knockout episode
last week because you got to play two
very different points of view yes yeah
it was a huge so challenge it was like a
play yeah it was directed by Sam gold
who's a big theatre director in New York
and it was huge we had the differences
are very slight but you know we had so
we had two weeks in the same room it's
like a chamber piece because the
question is is it murder or suicide for
Alison
I think it's murder I don't I mean it's
not I it's not entirely clear and also
you know is it the fantasy version of
the first half the second half is
reality I'm not coming back so she's
dead did you know the word is that you
wanted to leave is that true we leave
the show I did want to leave but I'm not
allowed to talk about why you're not
allowed to talk about no okay what when
you leave well Ruth I'm like wait a
second truth because what I heard was it
was a disagreement about money male and
female salaries I've never complained of
show time about pay parity okay alright
okay well we'll leave it at that it was
traumatizing I know in a good way I love
what's been amazing to me is the fan
response it's been absolutely I mean
really moving for me and to see that a
character like this has can connect with
people and for me what was amazing is
you know I have people very close to me
who've lost kids so it was always for me
really important to serve the story of
this woman that is defined by a gabriel
yeah also Marvel your British accent
your American accent is so good thank
you
to to team Alison Bailey
cheering you on always thank you go is
and you can see the little stranger in
theaters starting August 31st and the
season 4 finale of the affair will be on
Sunday night I will be watching on
Showtime a division of CBS